thank you
Torchlight guide Shoppers along the
shelves
Russia's almost nightly bombardment of
Ukraine's electricity and energy
infrastructure means millions of
ukrainians spend much of their daily
life in the dark
Toria is shopping with her
three-year-old son Daniel
they fled fighting near their home in
the Harrison region in April good
evening the authorities tell us they've
stabilized the electricity situation and
then there's another attack it's been
like this for the last two months
he's got used to the darkness and
importantly he's not afraid we have no
choice we have to get through this
Emergency Services battled fires across
Kiev and various locations throughout
the country after another Russian
bombardment early Monday morning
this home was completely destroyed in a
village close to Kiev by one of 30
so-called Kamikaze drones Ukrainian
military says it intercepted
it's scary thoughts of possibly becoming
homeless is terrifying everyone is
scared but we are bearing it
Maria and Denise have to carry their two
and a half year old son David up the
stairs to their apartment on the 13th
floor because electricity is down again
so the elevator doesn't work
ten days after the invasion as Russian
forces Advance towards their apartment
Block in European they fled to the
Netherlands and then France they have
only recently returned
Maria Comforts her son in bed and she
tries to send him to sleep
Denise has put plastic sheeting over the
windows for additional protection
against the Sub-Zero winter temperatures
it's pretty hard but we try not to
complain because we think of our
soldiers living in the trenches in
dismal conditions but on one occasion we
didn't have electricity for two days
yes it's cold sometimes the child is
coughing it's winter but we can get
through this we wait for spring and
Victory
nearby is one of thousands of heated
tents with generators put up in recent
weeks where people can get warm and
charge their devices as work continues
around the clock to fully restore
electricity and heating across the
country
Russia's drone and missile attacks
targeting Ukraine's energy
infrastructure are happening with
increasing frequency and that means that
many people in neighborhoods like this
one face another night without Heating
and in the dark Charles Stratford Al
Jazeera Kiev